[Musique]
on ne peut pas dire que les candidats
lâché free des conservateurs étaient
tout à fait les bienvenus à brut en
Écosse
la grande favorite et richissounac sont
venus plaider pour l'appui des membres
de leur partie mais à les entendre un
néophyse répandonné de croire qu'ils ont
tous les deux un adversaire commun dans
la course
[Applaudissements]
mais la première ministre écossaise et
chef du Parti national écossais le S&P
pèse lourd dans la campagne des
conservateurs ici pour gagner la
confiance de leurs membres résolument en
faveur de l'Union les deux prétendants
postes de Premier ministre doivent
démontrer à leur base qu'ils seront
freinés les ambitions séparatistes de la
dirigeante de l'Écosse
à l'extérieur du théâtre une poignée
retentissante de manifestants rappellent
aux candidats que l'indépendance de
l'école reste plus que jamais peut-être
d'actualité pour eux
d'une victoire décisive aux dernières
élections au Parlement écossais Nicolas
kergen entend bien aller au bout de sa
démarche référendaire d'ici un an on a
eu
l'ennui c'est que sa tenue doit être
confirmée par la Chambre des communes à
Londres un obstacle de taille pour le
contourner Nicolas stergen à sollicité
la Cour suprême britannique elle demande
un avis sur la légalité d'un tel vote
sans la corde du Parlement
[Applaudissements]
et le parfait exemple de ce qui a changé
en 2014 il a voté non et a fait
activement campagne pour rester au sein
du Royaume-Uni
people
62% des Écossais on va décontre le
brexit ce qui exacerbe pour certains un
sentiment d'isolement et d'impuissance
face à Londres on peut pas faire
qu'est-ce qu'on veut ici on n'a pas
toutes les pouvoirs et ici en école si
nous sommes à la gauche Westminster
c'est à la droite puis si on veut avoir
le pays à la gauche
avec l'argent pour tout le monde avec
qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire il faut avoir
l'indépendance
elena withem est député au parlement
écossais celle qui a grandi et fait ses
études au Québec avant de retrouver son
Écosse natale croit que si le référendum
sur l'indépendance de 2014 c'est seul
des par un échec avec
55,3 % des électeurs contre les
conditions actuelles rendent une
victoire à portée de main la dernière
fois on était à 25% et on était rendu à
45%
qui
maintient tous les jours on a une crise
de la queue de la vie
encore faudra-t-il qu'un vote ait lieu
dans l'hypothèse probable ou la Cour
suprême se prononce contre la légalité
d'un scrutin Nicolas stergen promet de
faire des prochaines élections
législatives britanniques un référendum
de facto sur l'indépendance Paris qui
pourrait lui coûter ses appuis qui sont
nationalistes certes sans pour autant
être indépendantiste ici Marie-Eve
Bédard Radio-Canada et d'Imbours